critics say oh YouTubers why don't you
get a real job that very common
statement reveals that a lot of people
have no clue the amount of grit and work
and mental energy it takes to start a
successful YouTube channel and so one of
the big reasons that new and small
YouTube channels fail is they don't
embrace the law of sacrifice in order to
go up you've got to give up sometimes we
think that we can kind of just dabble on
the side with the channel and we'll just
get lucky and it'll just blow up the
truth is what's more common is people
consistently uploading over weeks months
oftentimes years study any of the great
video podcasts or YouTube channels and
oftentimes they'll say yeah it was year
three it was year four it was year seven
when momentum really started to pick up